il s'en est fallu de peu cha am a dit ce
rennais d'origine afghane est rentré
d'afghanistan le 25 juillet dernier
c'est là bas que ce chef d'entreprise
passait ses vacances avec sa femme et
ses enfants lui ainsi que sa famille ont
pu rentrer à temps ce qui n'est pas le
cas de 45 rennais toujours coincés à
kaboul parmi eux une vingtaine d'enfants
chat ahmadi est depuis en contact avec
ces familles ils sont très très inquiets
de la situation
ils sont presque tous tout le monde
était riche réseau il sort pas sauf si
besoin pour aller faire des courses il
ya des familles qui n'habitent pas à
kaboul des paysans ils sont juste là
parce que je ne veux pas raté leur
chance
samadi tente aujourd'hui de mobiliser
l'opinion publique pour rapatrier ces
familles à ses côtés l'association d'art
afghanistan avec à sa tête ashmat froz
ce dernier nous explique que leurs
courriers et les demandes envoyées au
quai d'orsay sont restées lettre morte
on est tous munis faire des affaires
étrangères alexis aux députés on la
rappelle dans les médias tout en toutes
les démarches qui possible on le fait
mais pour l'instant vous nous n'avons
pas aucun résultat et pour l'ensemble
des varois en abaissant c'est décevant
il se sent abandonné par la communauté
internationale de l'autre côté la mairie
de rennes nous a fait savoir qu'elle
avait transmis les noms des familles
bloquées au quai d'orsay le ministère
des affaires étrangères quant à lui a
précisé au figaro qu aucune évacuation
ne pouvait se faire tant que l'aéroport
de kaboul ne serait pas rendu au trafic
aérien civil toujours avec l'espoir de
faire bouger les choses la diaspora
afghane rennaise organise une nouvelle
manifestation ce samedi à rennes la
troisième depuis le 28 août